doctor
sorry
are you here with us right now
unfortunately I only have two hands so
it's going to be rather challenging to
talk at the microphone and type the same
time so I I wanted to talk
I happen to just write something just
that came out just yesterday this is um
a long and somewhat
philosophical scientific and
technological essay about the title that
it gives there
um but let me let me kind of get towards
this and hopefully I will I will get to
this so I want to talk about kind of uh
what what the world is made of and how
that matters in terms of thinking about
things like AI
so one of the things that's been uh the
the sort of in different in different
stages and developments of science
people have had different ideas about
how to describe the world I kind of view
there as having been about four stages
of description that people have had kind
of the first stage in Antiquity was like
what's stuff made of is stuff made of
atoms oh there are lots of copies of the
same kind of atom this kind of thing
that was kind of the the structural view
of how to describe things and there are
many fields of science that still
basically are using this kind of
structural way of of thinking about how
things work notably time doesn't really
enter much in that description it's just
what's stuff made of then you get to the
the big thing that happened in the 1600s
where people realize that oh you can use
mathematical equations to describe the
natural world and you can write down an
equation that represents what this
system in nature is doing and those
equations have a notion of time for
example where you say well we've got an
equation and it's parameter t for time
time and you can set that to anything
you want and that will all be be a uh as
appropriate since I've spent a large
part of my life building a computational
language for for humans to be able to
express their thoughts in a
computational way I'm always curious
about communicating with other forms of
of intelligence and actually you know
it's it's fun because I realized you
know like a image generation generative
AI system is a place where you you it's
kind of a a potentially alien mind the
the way that a generative AI is trained
now it's you know it's got a bunch of
images from the web made by humans but
uh I just actually just yesterday
somebody did this experiment for me and
I was just looking at the results just
before this of you take a a trained you
know image generation system trained on
human images and then you say let me
modify its Mind by just changing the
weights and the thing what does it make
it will then be it will be a very good
generator of completely alien stuff
so I'll leave that I don't know the
answer to that yet that's a that's a
that's a a Coming Attraction but in any
case back to kind of the description of
the of the world in in different uh
forms so it was this kind of idea let's
describe the world using mathematical
equations okay there's a pretty
successful approach that led to a lot of
current science and engineering and so
on
question that came up is is there
anything one can do beyond that I got
interested in this in the in the
beginning of the 1980s kind of trying to
understand how do you get complex things
in the world and how do you explain how
those work and solving equations you
know some partial differential equations
for the shape of a snowflake doesn't
work very well so what what else can you
do and so I got interested in kind of
how if if there are definite rules for
describing how systems work how would
one make those rules as general as
possible and the obvious thing in our
current times is to think about programs
but we're really just thinking about
rules we just talk about those as
programs because programs are a thing we
we're we're familiar with so the
question was if you take just simple
programs for example and you just pick
programs sort of let's say even at
random in the computational universe of
possible programs what do they do and so
there's this kind of third approach to
thinking about how things work in the
world that you have the structural
approach from Antiquity you have the um
the kind of mathematical equations
approach and then you have the approach
of well let's just make rules based on
programs one thing that we'll talk about
a whole bunch is that the notion of time
is somewhat different in the case of
mathematical equations time is just a
variable a parameter you said it to be
whatever you want in the case of a
program time is something where you have
to specifically run the thing you go
this step to step this step it's not
something where you can just jump ahead
at least in the immediate way it's set
up to say well what does it do well you
know you can't just turn a knob to say
what time you get you have to actually
run through each step so the next
question is well what do typical
programs actually do and um
yeah let's let's uh I can just use these
um this is one of my
sort of a typical simple program of
cellular automaton just got a line of
cells each one is either black or white
at each step each cell is updated
according to that rule at the bottom
that says what to do based on uh based
on the color of that cell and it's
neighbors so very simple rule start off
with one black cell get very simple
Behavior you might say this is what has
to happen because if the rule is this
simple it's inevitable that the behavior
will be corresponding and simple because
that's kind of what we're used to from
doing things like engineering if we want
to make a very complicated thing in
engineering we expect we have to go to
lots of effort to do that okay try
another rule we get something like this
try um uh let's try another rule we get
um get something like this it's a little
bit more intricate we can let it run a
little bit longer we'll get a nice
fractal pattern so then the question is
okay let's turn our kind of
computational telescope out into this
computational universe of possible
programs and see what's out there
so this is uh the first 64 of those
possible programs just changing the bits
that represent the rule in the program
this is what we get so a lot of behavior
we see here has the feature that the
program is very simple the behavior is
correspondingly simple but my all-time
favorite science discovery which is
about to blank out here is um
oh dear oh no no no no no the okay hold
on let me just go back to that
and um
okay oh you see it now you see it all
right is is this
oh now I'm away from the microphone okay
is this creature um uh rule 30 here so
let's let's look at that in a bit more
detail
um
so here it is it just starts from one
black cell at the top and it uses that
very simple rule at the bottom and um
but if you run it a little bit longer
you'll see it produces something looks
to us very complicated you can see a
certain amount of regularity over on the
left but if you look for example at the
center column of cells here they'll seem
for purposes of of testing for
Randomness they'll seem for all
practical purposes random we use this
for many years in in mathematical modern
language as the source of pseudo-random
numbers and many many things in the
world have been studied with with that
pseudo random number generator and so
far as what anybody can tell it seems to
be perfectly random yet it came from
that very simple rule it's a completely
deterministic system every time you run
it you'll get the same result you just
start from one black cell that'll make
this okay so this is rather a remarkable
thing but in this computational universe
of possible programs it is it turns out
to be the case that it's very common to
get Behavior that's very complicated
even from very simple rules you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy